what do you got Heather okay not
Thanksgiving without cranberry dish I
know a lot of people like cranberries in
the can some people just don't like them
at all but for me these are like my
favorite thing in the entire world so
this is super simple I'm gonna walk it
through here you go there it is okay so
what you do um you're gonna grab this
grab your cranberries all you need to do
is just buy one pack of them it's super
easy then you're going to start with I
don't know like three quarters of a cup
of um either apple juice or orange juice
if you like it a little more tart and
then sugar and that's the key right you
can do Splenda as well so you are going
to basically put in the orange or apple
juice and the sugar put it in your pot
and it's going to let it boil add in
your seasonings which in this case is
like nutmeg cloves and cinnamon about a
quarter teaspoon of each let that boil
and kind of simmer add your cranberries
in here and then cook them until they
start popping it's going to take like
four or five minutes
and then cranberries and golden raisins
and this is about a half a cup of each
so there you go that is so much better
than when I see it it's not just from a
can of just like when you open it right
these are so easy to make oh please
please please okay I have to taste and
then of course if you're gonna make them
now stick them in the fridge right away
because they need to cool off okay
all right this is straight from the
kitchen of Mills it is I did I did make
these even though I couldn't figure out
how to make this work oh my gosh do you
like them oh I've already made mine
yesterday also mad at myself oh well
next year I should have waited I'm gonna
make your green beans are delicious
Sherry thank you John it's very simple
yeah
so simple and you really can't mess it
up I love it you got a video John come
on don't be green it's done you kind of
win I do I love that and we do want to
hear from you give us your inspiration
for your Thanksgiving tables recipes
online picks at 8newsnow.com we're going
to post them on our website so everybody
can see them I'll put mine up uh John
any pictures on the website too sure
is cracking it open though and not
having the biscuit fall out on the floor
yes well you know that's a work in
progress one year I'm gonna get it right
you will see does Ethan do you give him
the job of the biscuits too that's about
redundant 20. wow yeah we're still
impressed John we really are good